à l'origine de la polémique le livre
banlieue mon amour des portraits et
témoignages pour raconter la banlieue un
joli titre mais des phrases jugées
ambiguës sur les juifs qui colonisent
les quatre coins de la planète sur les
arabes et les africains en juillet jean
de boishue est poursuivi pour injure
raciale par sos racisme une plainte
retirée aujourd'hui un brutal revirement
après les regrets écrits du secrétaire
d'état d'avoir pu faire de la peine à
certains des propos qui selon sos
justifie son désistement
moi mon rôle dans la société française
n'est pas de faire tomber des ministres
mon rôle dans la société française c'est
que quand on blesse c'est quand
n'humilie des étrangers ont plus les
dédommager que ce soit sur les plans
moral comme ça a été fait ou que ça
puisse passer par la justice est de leur
que le ministre s'est excusé et bien
j'estime que les torts sont réparés et
puis voilà on a fait notre travail
il y a les regrets écrit mais aussi des
dédommagements financiers
le député maire rpr de brétigny va
verser ce et racisme les droits d'auteur
du livre contesté pour autant il ne
s'agirait pas de compensation financière
monsieur de boyaux de manière
unilatérale
seul sans contrepartie a décidé que les
droits d'auteur qu'il pourrait tirer de
cet ouvrage serait distribué verset sos
pour permettre à sos de poursuivre un
combat qui a tout les styles tous le
respect tout le soutien de monsieur
debré
malgré ce règlement à l'amiable sos
racisme poursuit son action contre
l'éditeur
ici linak un proche de jacques chirac
d'autre part un jeune de briques ni
maintient sa plainte
stevie gustave estime se reconnaître
ainsi que son père dans un portrait du
monsieur boillon a écrit des trucs qui
pour moi et pour toute ma famille sont
inqualifiables
donc je
je vais aller jusqu'au bout c'est jallet
jusqu'au bout pour que la vérité éclate
l'audience a été fixée au 7 novembre
prochain